when you think about people trying to
transition into technology industries so
we can use bitcoin and crypto or we
could use other ones and they don't have
a college degree what are some of the
tips or tricks that you uh share with
them as to how to increase the
probability that they're able to get
those jobs
sure so this is actually and a lot of
people think that there's a lot of
mysticism around this and something a
way that it gets dismissed quite often
is oh you must have had a connection but
i didn't um and that one that one tends
to get people but uh something that my
husband ryan who's also my podcast
co-host um something that we teach
people is we call it finding a job
backwards and so this is going to be a
little counter-intuitive because really
it's finding a job forwards but if you
were raised in an american school what
you're taught to do is you're taught to
buy first and ask questions later but
the thing is that kind of makes no sense
because here's the employee and here's
the business and you'll notice that the
college is nowhere involved in this
transaction
so it makes no sense to buy a piece of
paper that's supposedly a requirement
for a job without first checking to see
if the business will hire you without it
and so what we have people do is we have
people go through multiple job listings
so let's say looking through 20
different job listings and telling up
how often they see a skill or a
certification mentioned in the listing
and then going from there and learning
that thing and then applying for the job
so when you think about that the idea of
hey i know what i want to work uh from a
job perspective i can go and i can look
and if it doesn't say i need a college
degree then you know pretty obvious
maybe i don't need to go to college in
order to get that job uh talk to me a
little bit about the skills so if i read
through a job um kind of opening and i
see in the description it says hey you
need skill a b or c how do you guys uh
normally uh help people learn that skill
is it something where they can just go
on the internet and you know kind of
play around on on google or youtube and
end up learning or is there something
else
yeah so the the the thing that ryan and
i are really big on is trying to reduce
risk because the thing about college is
fundamentally it is just really
financially risky and it's so
interesting because it's been painted to
all of us sold to all of us really for
12 years as the safest investment that
somebody could make when in fact it's
one of the most high risk ones you could
make because if you're wrong you are out
i mean the average family spends 30k a
year um for us per student and then not
only that but most college graduates
take five and a half years to graduate
so you're talking about something that's
very time and money intensive so what we
tell people is look at the skills that
are listed and this is even if it does
say you know it requires a college
degree screw it like ignore that and
just look to see what skills it actually
says that you need so if what comes up
multiple times is they want you to learn
how to use adobe premiere you can learn
adobe premiere for free you know if it
tells you if the job description says
they need somebody who's really
competent with excel or can use sql or
needs basic knowledge of python all of
those things you can learn on the
internet for free so what we advise
people to do is look for zero cost
options that you can self teach and then
slowly increase your learning budget as
you go up